Kourtney Kardashian dishes on her health
secrets and difficult detox regimen
where he has three kids she's never
looked better she's like the hottest mom
ever the fit mama three opened up on her
app Wednesday and spilled on her
gluten-free lifestyle
first up Kourt reveals she does a
24-hour fast once a week quote on the
fasting days I drink bone broth and
water all day and then I'll have dinner
that evening so I basically just don't
eat breakfast and lunch that day
Kourtney's trick to curb her urge to eat
she says that on detox day she tries to
stay busy and avoids going to the
kitchen as for her meal plan the 38 year
old reality star says she sticks to a
low-carb diet containing no grains and
no beans for breakfast Kourt K takes it
easy on the fruit her go-to morning meal
is an avocado pudding smoothing with
banana and added supplements for lunch
and dinner she eats chicken or fish with
cauliflower rice and veggies think it's
like just as important what you put
inside is like what you put on your skin